District Attorney is investigating the
death of a puppy on a United Airlines
flight as a possible criminal offense
coquito a French Bulldog died after his
owner says the United flight attendant
in Houston forced her to put him in the
overhead bin United is also apologizing
this morning after it mistakenly flew a
German Shepherd to Japan the dog was
supposed to land in Kansas City with its
owners Kris Van Cleave is at O'Hara's
International Airport in Chicago Chris
good morning good morning United has
announced starting in April it will
issue brightly colored bag tags two
carry-on bags containing a live animal
that is the airline is apologizing for
this latest pet mistake now ergo that
German Shepherd should be back in the US
his owners expect some time tonight and
the Great Dane that was sent to Kansas
by mistake should have already made its
way to Tokyo I honestly don't know how
it could happen like a Great Dane and a
shepherd there are two completely
different dogs look nothing alike Kara
swindle says ten-year-old Peugeot is
expected home tonight two days later
than planned he was put on a plane
Monday in Portland stopping overnight in
a Denver kennel but on Tuesday instead
of flying to Kansas City
he made a nearly 6,000 mile detour to
Tokyo when her goes owner came to pick
him up United Airlines gave her a Great
Dane named Lincoln instead instant tears
this I just kept saying this is not my
dog like how is this happening this is
not my dog my son has been crying all
day because he wants his dog United
Airlines says we apologize for this
mistake an error occurred during
connections in Denver for two pets
sent to the wrong destinations your pet
is treated as cargo CBS News travel
editor Peter Greenberg says passengers
should be aware of airline policies when
traveling with pets if the airline
either misplaces your dog or cat or
injures it or kills it your compensation
is roughly the equivalent of a lost bag
there is no way to like replacing sophia
ceballos and her mother catalina Robledo
are still mourning the death of their 10
month old french bulldog coquito who
died on a United flight Monday after a
and told them to put his carrier in the
overhead bin he was like a brother he
was like a son for my mom the outrage
over little coquitos death has reached
Capitol Hill
Senator John Kennedy tweeted he'll be
filing a bill today that will prohibit
Airlines from putting animals in
overhead bins what happened to this cat
was disgraceful we need to get to the
bottom of it
now United is apologizing and has
apologized repeatedly taking full
responsibility for what happened the
airline does say that it now appears the
flight attendant was told that there was
a dog in that bag but the airline
believes she either didn't hear or
didn't understand what the customer was
saying United denies that the dog was
intentionally put any overhead bin Nora
thank goodness the story is kind of hard
though Nora because the passengers said
the dog was barking yeah the dog was
barking in the overhead compartment and
they had heard the dog barking yeah I
know I wonder what the other passengers
yes yes it's just heartbreaking all the
way around but you know that certainly
isn't funny it's not funny about the
dogs getting mixed up but when you see
the German Shepherd and the Great Dane
ones in Japan and once again that is not
my dog that is not my dog certainly not
in Kansas anymore that United has some
work to do over there can you imagine
the meetings that are going on in the
United headquarters yes let's do it now
make sure there's not another one of
these